for more on today's primary and the
March to delegate-rich Super Tuesday
we're joined by Anna Palmer she's the
senior Washington correspondent for
Politico and co-author of politics
playbook newsletter that's a mouthful
yeah morning a lot of jobs so a new
Monmouth poll has Joe Biden ahead of the
Democratic field in South Carolina is
this make or break for him and and if it
is where does he go from here the stakes
could not be higher for Joe Biden right
now he's really trying to resurrect his
presidential campaign and he has said
this is going to be where he shows that
he has a diverse coalition that's
backing him if he doesn't finish a
strong first I think that it's going to
be very hard for him to make the case on
Super Tuesday is going to be big for him
and to his donors to keep supporting him
what does he have to do on Super Tuesday
I think that's the question that they
had are totally being outspent in terms
of money in some of the big states and
also in terms of the ground game and so
the question is can they use this
first-place finish in South Carolina to
boost him to you know in some of these
other states Bernie Sanders right now
has a healthy lead in the delegate count
right I've heard some people say at this
point is Bernie or brokered is that the
case I think when you talk to Democratic
operatives as I have been they are more
and more certain that a brokered
convention is what we are going to see
in the coming in the coming month of
their preparation this can't happen for
that because there's a lot of
establishment Democrats who do not want
Bernie Sanders to be the nominee along
those lines the other things that you
hear is well if it is a brokered
convention what is the answer who is the
person that's with Bernie that would
give middle America a reason to vote for
the Democrats instead of for Donald
Trump he has not really given us any
look into what he's thinking for a vice
presidential nominee who he might pick I
think the question is going to be can he
really coalesce and bring kind of the
establishment in with him and but right
now there's no stopping him I mean he
really is the full runner in this race
is it surprising to you that nobody else
has sort of backed out absolutely I
think if you look at history right now
there would have been many of the
candidates Amy Klobuchar for example at
Tom Styer really had
had that momentum would have backed out
they have not they've all said they're
gonna continue through Super Tuesday and
so there really hasn't been that kind of
coalescing of the more moderate
candidate interesting watching the
markets right now too because generally
speaking when the economy is strong
president's re-elected when the
economy's not there not and we certainly
saw the the Dow to take a dive this week
largely on fears about Corona a lot of
people upset if Donald Trump just
campaigned on the economy or how it was
before this week he would be sailing to
reelection the question is going to be
can he save off this kind of downturn
what is in his toolbox in terms of the
corona virus to make people feel and
make the markets feel that he has
control the situation many months ahead
before our election in November Anna
thank you